-Excuse me.
-Hi.
-I am looking for
a lady's suit.
-Okay. What kind?
-A successful business suit.
-Ooh! Like Connie Chung,
or like "Dynasty"?
-This episode is about a young
woman trying to figure out
a way to make ends meet
for her and her son,
and ends up opening
a cookie business
by selling in a very traditional
"Ugandan marketplace" way.
-You go out there like that?
-That's gonna make you famous!
-The character is actually based on
a real story,
Elizabeth Kizito,
who is a Ugandan woman who came here
and started her own business
selling cookies in Louisville.
-How's that staying on
your head right now?
-African magic.
-So, I'm an immigrant, and I
came to the States for college,
and so I feel like I brought
my own life experience,
since I know what it is
to be in this country,
I know what it is to want to
succeed in this country.
-The talent on this episode
is fantastic.
I think Kemi and Innocent,
who plays her son,
they bring a sense of
authenticity and playfulness
that is really infectious
to the crew and the set.
-The crew's amazing.
From the props
to the wardrobe, everything,
it just goes through
this filter of
"Are we doing it as
realistically as we can?"
The episode that
we're shooting right now,
the toe polish wasn't right,
and the hair and makeup people
caught it and just immediately
started scrubbing the toes
right before we started shooting
'cause that color nail polish
did not exist in 1981
in Louisville.
-And cut.
-If people feel a connection to
Beatrice as a person,
and can see her as a full
character, that would be ideal.
Somebody who's not
a perfect human being,
but somebody who has dreams
and obstacles just like the rest of us.
-It's a beautiful story
and a beautiful TV show
that, week after week,
will remind you
of all these beautiful cultures that
these people bring in to this country.
-My mommy is the cookie lady.